la guerra en afganistán comenzó a la
sombra de los ataques del 11 de
septiembre cuando el jefe de al qaeda
osama bin laden fue protegido por el
talibán en afganistán
un mes después eeuu decidió invadir el
país el 7 de octubre de 2001
estas acciones cuidadosamente planeadas
están diseñadas para interrumpir el uso
de afganistán con una base de
operaciones terroristas y para atacar la
capacidad militar del régimen talibán
los talibanes que profesan una línea
dura del fundamentalismo islámico habían
llegado al poder cinco años antes con el
apoyo del gobierno paquistaní en su
mandato lo salió danés prohibieron la
música el arte y la educación a las
mujeres pronto las fuerzas
estadounidenses vencieron al grupo
insurgente retirándose pakistán y a
otros países en 2004 a raíz de las
primeras elecciones democráticas del
país hamid karzai enemigo de los
talibanes llegó al poder el grupo
insurgente lejos de desaparecer se
enfrentó a las fuerzas afganas y formó
una resistencia financiada en parte por
el tráfico de drogas
paralelamente cuando barack obama
sucedió a george w.bush como presidente
del país prometió retirar las tropas
pero una escalada de violencia lo llevó
a mandar más soldados en 2010 100 mil
tropas estadounidenses estaban
territorio además de 50.000 tropas de la
otan el mundo no puede permitirse el
precio que deberá pagar si afganistán
vuelve a caer en el caos o si al qaeda
opera sin control después del asesinato
de bin laden en 2011 una parte de las
tropas se retiró sin embargo otra se
quedó apoyando el entrenamiento de las
fuerzas del gobierno
los talibanes continuaron sus ataques
primero las tropas extranjeras deben
irse solo después la paz será posible en
el fondo la toma de kabul le da un giro
20 años de guerra en la que 3.500
soldados extranjeros a cerca de 51 mil
civiles y 69 mil militares afganos
murieron en los enfrentamientos